with all of that in mind why not stay  safe stay home  ring in the new year with us once again  channel 8 is covering celebrations all  across the country on new year's eve  brian loftus and kirsten joyce host our  show starting just before 9 on new  year's eve  all the way past midnight eight news now  will be live from stadium swim at  downtown's new circa resort  we'll have performances from zoe bowie  the eli young band  and strip headliners like tape face our  team will be socially distant  screened and tested for covet we hope  you can spend a safe new year's eve  with us during our program we're also  raising money for food banks across the  country  with the super bowl of caring we're  trying to raise money for a million  meals  any money that you donate will stay  right here in las vegas